hello everybody my name is nya and i'm
the black female engineer i provide
content for new and aspiring software
engineers
and today we are going to be talking
about salaries
specifically the three salaries i was
offered after
my coding bootcamp these are three
different jobs all some type
of iteration of developer engineer and
they were all
entry-level roles so keep that in mind
however
very quick don't forget to add me on
instagram and
dm me with any question you may have
about me software engineering
coding boot camp anything at all because
i will be filming a q a video
where i'll be answering these questions
directly and giving you a shout out as
well because i just
love engaging with you all so yeah go on
over there after
this video i'll be going through this
chronologically so not based on
um salary range or lowest to highest or
anything like that
i'll be going through this based on when
i received my offer
so let's get to it job number one
i received this offer about three hours
after my coding bootcamp graduation so i
was very grateful
very happy that day and this
offer was for 68 000 base
on top of this there was also a 5 000
starting
um bonus as well i wouldn't get it you
know until
after i had been working there for a
couple weeks um i don't remember how
much time i would have had to be working
there for me to finally get it i think a
couple weeks at most
so this made the total year one
compensation package 73
000 because of that 5 000 bonus
but then every year thereafter would be
a 68 000 yearly compensation because
that is the base now for me i had
started this job hunt
um with a certain salary minimum in mind
this was based on the average salary of
a
entry level you know developer in my
location i highly highly recommend using
resources like levels.fyi
or glassdoor or other you know
calculators salary calculators or
anything like that
i'll link those two down below because
those were like
what i was you know living on when i was
going through job hunts
but i recommend using these to just
have a better understanding of what you
can expect and not expect
what you should ask or not ask for well
maybe not not ask for i'll never say
don't ask for
something but yeah what um you should go
into this job hunt um presuming
expecting etc so i'll link those below
but yes for me
my minimum um was 75 000
that was based on the location based on
the
entry level position this will change
based on
if you're looking at mid-level roles if
you're looking at senior roles but i was
looking at entry level rules
and so yeah my mineral was 75 000 and
that was for
base and so i was a bit
disappointed when i got that first um
job offer
especially because i had kind of just
been in the mindset of after
if i get you know this job offer i am
hanging it up i am done looking for jobs
like i
i can't because it is so mentally toning
all you see is the announcements on
linkedin and everything of the new jobs
someone got
you don't see the 200 applications that
they sent to finally get
two callbacks or to finally you know the
ridiculous amount of negotiation they
had to do to finally get
paid paid fairly but you know that's a
conversation for a different day
but but yeah you don't um people don't
talk about how mentally tolling it is
and it's really mentally tolling and by
then i was so
over it like i was like lord please like
i i can't keep doing this
and um so i had been very happy i had
gotten the job offer but also
disappointed
um that the salary was
below my minimum so i decided to just
you know put my big girl pants on and
just
keep looking for you know a few more
weeks a few
one or two months just keep on
interviewing keep on connecting and just
see what happens the next offer i got
didn't happen until about three weeks
after
this also was for an entry level
position and the offer
i got was 80 000
base so that was very exciting
um yeah it was very very exciting
and they also had a bonus they had
a twelve thousand dollar bonus um
added on to the offer which half
would have been paid at signing and then
half would have been paid as a starting
bonus after working again maybe for a
few week days for a few weeks something
like that
i was very enthused um especially you
know when you know that
after you sign this then you get cash
right then and there so this brought the
total year one compensation
to 92 000 but then every year after to
80 000
because that was the base i felt in
terms of salary i felt very comfortable
i felt that it was something that
i could definitely sign on and you know
just work there and all of that
now hold up because about
three minutes later i received another
job offer and this offer
was for ninety thousand dollar base and
ten thousand dollar starting bonus
and so you can imagine just how enthused
i was on the phone for that you know
that time period where i just got
back-to-back offers that was just
a very very exciting moment very much
grateful that i was patient very
grateful that um i got to that point
and so for job number three
it brought the total compensation for
year one
to a hundred thousand dollars and then
ninety thousand dollars every year
there after because that was the base
now funny story on this very quick but
history i didn't realize
that it was a ninety thousand dollar
base until like
until more time than i would care to um
admit
because over the phone i had thought
that they had offered me 80
000 base with a 10k uh starting because
over the phone
um these are all all the offers i got
initially were all over
the phone and so um for job number three
it was no different and over the phone
um the person i was speaking to said you
were offering you
90 000 um including a 10k
signing or 10k starting bonus and so to
me
i thought that was 80 000
plus 10k to be 90 000 total
so you can imagine my surprise when
x amount of time goes by and i finally
like i get the actual like offer
letter and it lists the um benefits
and the you know the offer and
everything and i see
the number 90 and the number 10
on you know a whole different line i was
like oh my gosh it's a 90 000
base because um sometimes you don't get
the
actual letter until a few days or a few
weeks
after um because that stuff does take
time to just take you know certain
you know authority figures and
just lawyers and like things like that
and so sometimes you don't get that till
um a little bit after and so yeah
imagine my surprise when i open that
letter and i see a whole ten thousand
more um so you know i'm not going to say
which job i took
but but no no for real though
no matter and this is like y'all might
roll your eyes at this
each of the jobs if they had given me
the same exact offer i still would have
gotten
gone with the job i chose even if to be
honest even if the job i chose
offered a little bit less than the
others i still
would have gone with this job because
when i looked at values when i looked at
the type of environment that they had
the type of vibe they set in the office
their
initiatives and what they hope to see in
the future it just meshed
so well with me on a personal and
professional
level all of these companies were three
very different companies
um both in terms of the industry they
worked in their business model
and um their like
what's the word i don't want to say vibe
um what's the word like their values
i feel like there's another word
i don't know i don't know but yeah in
terms of their vibe not just values
in terms of their vibe they were three
very very different companies
and so something to think about is
of course of course salary is important
i'm not saying so like i was a finance
major like
money is important like i'm not saying
don't think about it
but along with that think about how a
company makes you feel now i know like
some people are gonna like roll their
eyes when they hear this
but if you are interviewing with a
company if you're interacting with them
going through the application process
and they constantly
just maybe don't bring off the best
vibes
maybe they you know make you feel a
certain way in certain situations and
certain you know interview questions or
things like that
remember that like lean into that and
really think about it because
an interview and like the application
process is when
the company should like be its best you
know what i mean because they're trying
to bring people in and so
if during that process you don't feel
great then imagine
how it's going to be once you start
working there i'm not saying that if
they made you feel great
during the interview you're going to
feel great doing the job like there are
tons of times where then companies flip
up on you
and then it's like this is not the same
company i interviewed for x amount of
months ago
um so i'm not saying that but if they
can't even
be you know amazing and be very
um kind and thoughtful
during your the application and
interviewing and recruitment process
that is in my experience not a good sign
for what awaits you at the other end
of that offer if you decide to join the
company
all of that so really go into this
writing down a list of things that are
most important to you
with um this job that you know you hope
to have
and see where salaries tax up on that is
that number one is it number two is
number
three is it the last thing on the list
while you know assist
education assistance is the first thing
or um
vacation is is the second thing like
look at
the different um things that
you would accept or deny an offer
for and really just rank them and when
you start getting your offers and
you will start getting your offer i
believe in manifestation you will get
there
really just um bring out that list again
because it's fun and dandy when you see
the number
at first but then when you take a look
at all the other parts the job would
encompass and the people you'd be
working with and things like that
that's when it can either make you want
the job more
or actually say you know what this
salary isn't worth it but yeah i think
all y'all can guess which job i chose
but
it's not because of the salary it's
really not it's because of how they made
me feel
and um just me being very excited to
work for them
so no if you liked this video please let
me know by hitting that like button by
subscribing
and please let me know how this job plan
has been going for you either
through instagram dm me or put in the
comments i love interacting with you all
so much
so don't be shy don't be shy i'm here
i'm you know i'll
let let's talk so i'll see y'all
later bye y'all